CONGRESSMAN KING SUPPORTED THE
PRESIDENT PRECISELY BECAUSE OF
HIS IMMIGRATION VIEWS ALONG WITH
OTHER ISSUES.
AND JOINING US NOW WITHOUT
FURTHER ADO IS CONGRESSMAN STEVE
KING AND WE'RE DELIGHTED HE'S
JOINING US FROM IOWA, I BELIEVE.
CONGRESS, HOW ARE YOU DOING?
>> DOING FINE RIGHT IN MY LIVING
ROOM.
IT'S TERRIFIC.
I APPRECIATE YOUR MONOLOGUE.
>> Sean: LET'S TALK ABOUT THE
PRESIDENT'S PLAN.
THE FOUR PILLARS WERE ANNOUNCED
LATE YESTERDAY.
IT'S A CHANGE FROM A WEEK AGO
WHERE IT WAS 800,000 DACA
RECIPIENTS WOULD HAVE A PATHWAY,
EVENTUALLY, TO CITIZENSHIP AND
MOVED ON TO 1. MILLION -- 1.8
MILLION BASICALLY IN PLACE AND
MORE FOR THE BORDER AND SECURITY
WHICH IS GOOD STUFF AND THE VISA
LOTTERY SYSTEM WOULD BE KIND OF
REPLACED -- USED THE 50,000 TO
END THE FAMILY AND MERIT-BASED
BACKLOG OF ILLEGAL IMMIGRANTS
WHO HAVE BEEN APPLYING AND
WAITING FOR YEARS AND YEARS.
TELL US WHAT YOUR BIGGEST
CONCERN IS WITH THIS AND COULD
LEGAL IMMIGRATION?
>> I HAVEN'TSTEIN
I HAVEN'T SEEN THE PLAN BUT I DO
RECOGNIZE THE VALUE OF THE GO
GOODLATTE BILL BUT THE NUMBERS
ARE STUNNING THAT PRESIDENT
TRUMP PROPOSED 1.8 MILLION
AMNESTY TO ILLEGALS.
I'M FAMILIAR WITH THE
IMMIGRATION POLICY.
I SAID THE POLICY HAS BEEN IN
IOWA 14 YEARS AND THAT'S WHY
HE'S PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED
STATES TODAY.
I THINK THIS WILL DEMORALIZE SO
A MANDATE FOR A WALL AND TO END
CHINE MIGRATION AND TO END THE
VISA LOTTERY.
WE CAN GO ON AND ON.
AND THEY'RE MATCHED UP
NEGOTIATIONS AND IT'S TROUBLING
TO ME.
I THINK SEEING THE DEMOCRATS
TURN AGAINST IT.
THE ONE THING HE'S ACCOMPLISHING
IS DEMOCRATS DON'T CARE ABOUT
SOLVING THE PROBLEM.
THEY WANT THE PROBLEM TO EXPLOIT
IT POLITICALLY AND TO BRING MORE
AND MORE PEOPLE INTO THE UNITED
STATES TAB ON THEIR SIDE OF THE
EXPOSED THEM.
IT'S NOT THE PLAN I WOULD WANT.
I'M GOOD FOR THE GOODLATTE BILL.
I SHOULD SHOW WHAT MERCEDES
SCLAP SAID I WANT TO HEAR FROM
THE WHITE HOUSE.
I'D LIKE TO INTERVIEW THE
PRESIDENT ON THIS AND OBVIOUSLY
HE JUST CAME BACK TONIGHT.
WE HOPE TO HAVE SOMEONE ON ON
MONDAY.
LET'S LISTEN TO WHAT MERCEDES
SAID EARLIER FROM THE WHITE
HOUSE TODAY.
>> CLEARLY IT NEEDS TO BE A
BIPARTISAN BILL.
IF WE COULD CLEARLY HAVE A 60
VOTES WITH REPUBLICANS THAT
WOULD SUPPORT THIS IT WOULD BE
EASIER.
THE CONGRESS IS NOT IN THAT
POSITION.
THAT'S WHY YOU NEED A COMPROMISE
ON IMMIGRATION AND FROM THE
STANDPOINT OF THE WHITE HOUSE
IT'S CLEAR THE PRESIDENT HAS
SAID TIME AND TIME AGAIN, THERE
NEEDS TO BE A WALL.
IF THERE'S NO WALL, THERE'S NO
DACA.
>> Sean: CONGRESSMAN, YOUR
RESPONSE.
THE GOODLATTE BILL WOULD BE DEAD
ON ARRIVAL AND NOT PASS.
WHAT DO YOU SAY?
>> NO WALL, NO DEAL.
THE REASON WE NEED THE WALL IS
THE WALLS DON'T HAVE
PROSECUTORIAL DISCRETION.
>> Laura: YOU GET THE WALL AND
DEAL AND END CHINE  -- CHAIN
MIGRATION.
THAT'S 400,000 PEOPLE A YEAR.
IN FIVE YEARS YOU'D HAVE MORE
THAN 1.8 MILLION AMNESTY OF NEW
FAMILY-BASED IMMIGRATION THAT'S
GONE.
IN FIVE YEARS YOU'D SWAP THE 1.8
NUMBER AND EXCEED IT AND THE
CUTS WOULD STILL KEEP COMING.
I DON'T SEE YOU'LL GET A CUT IN
LEGAL FAMILY CHAIN MIGRATION.
I DON'T SEE IT.
>> LAURA, HERE'S WHAT THIS
ESTABLISHES, THOUGH, IF THE
PRESIDENT SERVED UP 1.8 MILLION
IN AMNESTY IN CHANGE FOR $25
MILLION FOR A WALL AND THEN
ENFORCEMENT IN HIS
UP BECAUSE HE'LL HAVE
OF LAW.
WE'LL NEVER SEE THE RULE OF LAW
RESTORED AGAIN.
IN 1986 THIS MISTAKE WAS MADE BY
RONALD REAGAN.
IT'S THE SAME DEBATE.
IT HASN'T CHANGED.
>> Laura: RULE OF LAW HAS TO BE
RESPECTED, AGREE WITH YOU ON
THAT.
INGRAHAM OF LEFT-WING
LEFT-WING ADVOCATES SAID.
HATEFU
HATEFUL
CALL THE PROPOSAL WHAT IT IS A
TOP IN RESPONSE.
MY LISTERS CAN'T BELIEVE WHAT
THEY'RE HEARING BUT THE
PRACTICAL INFORMATION OF ALL
THIS IS YOU DON'T HAVE 60 STEVE
KINGS IN A SENTENCE.
VOTING FOR CLOTURE ON
IMMIGRATION PROPOSAL.
I WISH WE HAD MORE PEOPLE THAT
BELIEVED IN THE RULE OF LAW.
>> I LOOKED AROUND A WEEK AGO
AND HAD A HARD TIME FINDING
THANK YOU FOR DOING THIS
TONIGHT.
I APPRECIATE IT.
>> Laura: WE APPRECIATE IT, BY
THE WAY, CONGRESSMAN, WE COULD